ever had a band or an artist you're
obsessed with well for one man the music
of Bruce Springsteen is a lifelong
passion safra's Mansour fell in love
with the boss while growing up in
working-class England and history is the
basis for the new movie blinded by the
lights out in theaters nationwide this
weekend Anthony Mason met up with him
with a place that helped launch
Springsteen's career the Stone Pony in
Asbury Park New Jersey
[Music]
in blinded by the lights the teenage
Javad find salvation in the music of
Bruce Springsteen
[Music]
so what this film is is about how a 16
year old kid in Britain from a Pakistani
background has his life transformed by
an artist and a singer thousands of
miles away over New Jersey its
screenwriter safra's managers own story
and it started in 1987 with an encounter
in school when his friend rupes told him
Bruce Tatara client oldest Ronny won't
seriously what does he know about our
words got these with your life you can
thank me later
manzoor quickly became a convert
[Music]
I listen to everything I could seen it
all right here
it's like Bruce knows everything felt
Springsteen was speaking about growing
up in a dead-end town not getting on
with his dad having creams that seemed
you know bigger than him
and I thought this is my life he's
actually singing about my life you think
that this man sings but be but like us
but he talks to me
you cannot be serious night what did
your friends think when you started be
interested in Springsteen the weird
thing is they thought that we were odd
but we thought that we were better than
them because we thought we had wisdom
that they didn't have you had the secret
we had the secret you ended up making a
pilgrimage here I did 1990 I was 19
years old yeah
first trip to America I think the first
place I want to go to is Asbury Park do
you visit I'm going to see Bruce
Springsteen hometown I can't think of a
better reason to visit the United States
and to see the home with the boss man
[Music]
xuer and rupes
posed together on the boardwalk all the
places that Springsteen had been singing
about I wanted to see for myself
did it disappoint no man's or first told
his story in his 2007 memoir greetings
from Barry Park a play on the title of
Springsteen's first album a few years
later at a London film premiere he saw
Springsteen supple he stops he notices
me and he comes right up to me
and I've got this on video and that was
sort of the opening trigger that made me
think well if he likes the book maybe
there might be a 4-minute Mainzer would
spend 7 years writing the script this is
a foreign audience of one forget the
financier forget the producers we just
need something Bruce will like because
you can't make a film like this without
his music it's not gonna happen it's
gonna be a silent movie
[Music]
Springsteen signed off on the project
after the film was shot outside London
director Gurinder Chadha showed Bruce
and early cut a big kiss and said thank
you for looking after me so beautifully
Mainzer returned to Asbury Park last
week for the US premiere attended by a
surprise guest turn round I'm in the
middle of doing an interview a 10-round
that's Bruce and I think is nobody knew
for sure that he would turn up
[Music]
springsteen even performed at the
premiers after-party it's incredibly
powerful like somebody who whose work
you have admired so much and you come to
his hometown to show the film and he
endorses it by turning up mm-hmm
and how special is that like the perfect
ending it's a fairy tale there are no
words just songs apparently so amazing
the chance encounter that he had with
Bruce that eventually led to the movie
I'm a huge fan of Govinda chaja as she
she she directed Bend It Like Beckham
and they're both stories about people
who were outsiders who really are in
they really are they're no different
from the rest of us just have dreams so
you do that video along the line when
he's had read the book and he's like
totally shocked that I read it like cool
stuff you got to love it all well I'm
still waiting for my Bruce Springsteen
concert Robin go let's go a bit later